in the following video i will show you
how quickly and simply you can analyze
your data directly online with data tab
in order to do this go to datadeb.net
and click on the online statistics
calculator
then click on clear table and insert
your own data into the table
i will now use the example data once you
entered your data
the variables that you want to analyze
appear here below
it is important to make sure that the
names of your variables
appear in the first row in these steps
you will find the methods you need to
analyze your data
in the first step you can analyze your
data descriptively
for example you can display the mean
value
or the standard deviation you can also
create
frequency tables and crosstabs
in the next step you can perform a
variety of hypotheses tests
tata dab always helps you to find the
right test
an example in your survey you ask men
and women about their salary
now you want to know whether men and
women differ in terms of salary
in order to find it out you select the
variables
salary and gender now data tab tells you
which test is suitable for your question
and suggests
the t-test for independent samples if
the conditions for the independent
t-tests are not
met you can calculate a non-parametric
test
the mann-whitney u test of course you
can also calculate
many other hypotheses tests with data
tab
for example if you click on a nominal
variable with more than two values
an analysis of variance is automatically
performed
so this means data tab always suggests
the appropriate test
depending on which variables you select
what other methods are available in
datadeb.net
of course you can also easily calculate
a correlation
analysis a regression analysis
a principal component analysis and a
cluster analysis
so this was a first overview of the
possibilities of data tab
you can find more detailed information
about the statistical methods in our
tutorials
or you can take a look at our youtube
channel
thanks for listening